hi my name is P Attica I'm a molecular
biologist by training I studied here in
Munich where I also did my PhD research
in microbiology actually working on hiko
back to primary on the cell biology side
so a bit exotic I've been with nano
temper technologies now for two and a
half years I started in customer support
and now I'm part of the product
management team nano temper technologies
has been around since 2008 our goal is
to enable researchers to do the best
science of their lives so we're really
passionate about science and research
and we want to help people really be
more efficient and to good research easy
and fast
we have two major product lines out
there one of them is called monolith so
one of the instruments are for looking
at them molecular interaction so binding
affinity measurements and the other
product line is the Prometheus line that
looks at protein stability more exactly
thermal stability and which well you can
look at it from a conformational
standpoint in a colloidal standpoint so
we look at unfolding and we look at
aggregate of the protein when heating it
that can be really important to look at
it from different size and it enables
really a detailed characterization of
your protein stability what I want to
show today is this poster that talks
about different examples of Prometheus
applications in the workflow of drug
discovery and development and of course
this process the track discovering
development process is really long and
really complicated has many steps and
the more you can improve on it a better
and it always helps those researchers at
that step and to do better research and
we found that we can actually use the
Prometheus in several places there
they're all lined up on the poster as
you can see and I want to highlight a
couple of those today so the first one
is a project and that we did in
collaboration with Birmingham
where we looked at long-term stability
of biologics you know that biologics or
any type of protein of course can be
tricky because they are not necessarily
stable all the time but you need them to
be stable if it's a drug you need it to
be stable for a while so you have to
find those that can be stable you have
to find the right conditions to keep
them stable the right buffer the right
formulation what we did with Prometheus
was we performed some experiments or
within a day that are potentially able
to substitute the standard work flow
occurring at Ingelheim that takes them
17 months so that would be great of
course and would enable people to really
only use with the promise they work with
the promising candidates and not waste
time on those that don't make it at the
end so what you do what they commonly do
is you take a protein you look at it now
and then you wait for 17 months and then
you look at it again and see if it's
still okay of course that takes 17
months the prometheus was able to look
at the same thing in a day looking at
thermal unfolding of the protein at
dome-like Legation and at chemically
unfolding also so by using these three
different points of view on protein
stability we were able to look at
different formulations for a protein and
rank them which one keeps the protein
most stable and we got the same ranking
that bearing also got with their
standard workflow of looking at protein
stability after 17 months so this can
really help predict long-term stability
and can really help save a lot of time
effort and money of course in this
research workflow the second example is
comparison so we want to compare
Prometheus to other methods out there
that do similar things this is about
micro DSC it's also a technology for
looking at protein thermal stability and
you can see that we compare of course
really well the Prometheus gets the same
kind of data and gets the same quality
of data as DC but we get it using a lot
less sample and a lot faster so that's
really great benefits of the Prometheus
and we hope that more people can benefit
from that to make research more
efficient and the third example is one
that is not just relevant to people
working in drug discovery and
development
but to pretty much anybody working with
proteins because it's a general look at
keeping proteins happy and so you can
use the Prometheus to look at different
buffers for example different storage
conditions for your protein different
stress treatments and so on that you can
really look at the protein use the best
conditions for it and make sure it's
happy for the experiments you want to do
after so summing all of them up of
course I hope that I could show you that
the promises is useful in many many
places not just but also in the tract
discovering development workflow and if
you feel free to have a closer look at
the poster if you've got me curious or
if you have any other question feel free
to contact us our website is nano Tampa
tech comm and we're always happy to help
and we're all scientists ourselves and
we know what it's like to be in your
shoes and we'll try our best to find
good solutions for you and your research
so I'd like to thank you and I'm hoping
that we'll be in touch bye bye